every year I spend time thinking about
what are the technologies going from
deceptive to disruptive this year that
today's exponential leaders need to be
thinking about actually beginning to
work with and for this coming year for
the next few years my view is that the
virtual reality is part of that and it's
gotten different terms and their
different elements of it virtual worlds
virtual reality augmented reality and
really the kickoff was the purchase of
oculus rift by by Facebook for a couple
of billion dollars but in addition to
that what we've seen in is a number of
technologies coming together infinite
computing very cheap high-resolution
cameras machine learning capabilities
low latency high bandwidth networks all
of these things are coming together to
reinvent the virtual world experience
I'll give you one example of the virtual
world that I think is important today
when I go to a mall to buy things it's a
disastrous experience right you spend
half an hour getting to the mall you
park you go you're trying to find a
particular jacket or outfit whatever it
might be you look you can't find what
you're looking for you take few things
to the dressing room you try it on
doesn't fit you know you spend hours
it's a wasted experience and you walk
away frustrated in the future what I
project happening is at home you will
have yourself 3d scanned down to the
millimeter where it's a private file but
my body shape exactly is in a file I
then enter into a virtual world and I
have an AI there that is my shopping
adviser it says Peter what you're
looking for I'm saying I'm going to a
you know this amazing Hollywood party
tomorrow night and I'm looking for
something that's stylish I want to wear
black and all of a sudden in this
virtual world everything I see is in my
size in the colors I want recommended by
this AI and I can say you know I'd love
to see a fashion show
and all of a sudden on a on a on a
runway our avatars of me wearing all
these different outfits walking by and I
can say I want I want to see that one in
that one and all of a sudden I'm looking
in a virtual mirror and I'm wearing that
outfit and I can look around see what it
looks like and I go this is it
I want that boom it's produced
manufactured to my exact size probably
using 3d printing capabilities or
robotic capabilities that afternoon in
the local Factory and deliver it the
next morning and it fits perfectly so
it's a experience where when I want
something I know I will get exactly what
I'm looking for fitting for me so that's
the future of the virtual retail store
if you would and one I think virtual
reality is going to do effectively a
hundred fold improvement over what the
Amazon experience is today